I went through the 60s in college a
political I had come from this nice
Republican home where I was learning to
be a good Patriot and never met anybody
who had experienced any impression when
I went to college everything opened up
it was the 60s and I was avoiding
anything political I would just like oh
you're going talk politics on leave and
yet there was one thing that fascinated
me and that was the farm workers because
I had heard about Cesar Chavez refusing
to have a nice painting job refusing to
be paid wellis that had to this Union he
was founding because he wanted to be
poor like the workers and that was the
only reason I wanted to go when somebody
said I'm having somebody come over to my
house talk about the ufw anybody want to
come I went not knowing that would
totally changed my line that was the
turning point in my life one of them
because I came out politicized and the
next thing you know I'm on farmer her
picket lines and doing a delegation to
the local market asking them not sell
the grapes and but you know the gala
wine and lettuce
mom suggested I get a credential to
quote fall back on in case I didn't
become a screenwriter right out of
college the problem is just the worst
reason world for the teaching before can
I ended up loving it you know I probably
would have made it a screenwriter and
this children's book writer if I had had
a really boring job if I could have come
home from 0 hate my work you know it
just is boring its drudgery I can't take
it I just go and I just develop my
grading curve but instead is coming home
from this really exciting job but very
draining job of teaching especially
since I got them in our city teaching
it's the most time-consuming career
there is and nobody told me that my
brother Randy was really great at tap
ray more like ballet I like the ballet
in the tap and acrobatics a little but
mom and dad were amateur photographers
we had a dark room that they would turn
our service porch into and so we all got
dressed up in our favorite costumes me
and my gypsy Randy and his Buster Brown
and Ray in this toy soldier I remember
so many pictures of me the only person
they've all standing on their left foot
kicking their right foot in there I am
facing the other direction and standing
on both what that mean I guess I wasn't
quite as oh it's look girl oh it's just
looks really shy I was actually born in
summon it's a little suburb of LA in the
northern port that was my world for a
while growing up in the 50s very much a
lily-white community although I went to
Catholic schools but you're like magnets
if there any Latinos in the community
you're likely to have a bigger
concentration
of them in the city and then I just
discovered the real world a little later
after going the Catholic High School in
Glendale I went away to whittier mom
wanted made to be far enough away so i
can bring home in laundry and close
enough so we can still do things
together hey great parents similar in
junior high school we were doing career
date it's just like what I want to be
when I grow you know what do you mean
but I won't be thanks you know but in
junior high on this other girl said I'm
going to be a writer and I thought oh
almost books they're written by people
those movies they're made by people
writing the story down than the actors
to Rio this one crazy and so I just I
knew I'd be a writer always brought into
the world by a female doctor and so even
though in the 50s it was just not
promoted but my mom she was just summon
a step ahead of that and she told me and
she told my co brothers we could be
anything you wanted to me and I didn't
really know there would be limitations
when I was a kid my family would go out
to a drive-in movie and in my family
station wagon and it got to the point
where I just didn't like the ending I
didn't like it was going that since I
could do better unless and I'd pretend
to be sleepy and then I get in the back
end and curl up in that wonderful little
cozy little place in the back of the
station wagon and rewrite the ending and
follow the characters I had been
watching when I was in second grade I
was in church and my family and looked
down at the church bulletin and there
was my name and there was this little
paragraph there
I wrote that in my classroom but you
know all 72 of the second greatest of
that school had written the same
paragraph was the same assignment I
think mine it was like you know it's a
child's version of a Pulitzer until mom
said how are you going to wear your hair
when you're wearing the mortar board and
in the cap and gown for graduation and I
knew I couldn't put a mortarboard head
over that so I said oh I loan she said
12 wearing that new surfer girls style I
said straight it yeah that's it and she
said just for that one day and so he
didn't I've never worn it any other way
since was three months in between um one
teaching job and subbing in a school
district and I just assumed it would be
Los Angeles somewhere so I was going to
be full-time working for five dollars a
week plus room and board and then which
is so exciting i put in the next year
after that so I had been assigned to I
won't say the name of this town because
they were so conservative and they were
so so like I was when I was raised i
would say hi I'm um volunteer with the
United Farm Workers and I'd say the
United pharmacist I swear I heard that
so many times there and everybody was
crossing a picket line if I found
somebody would even stop and talk I was
just like ok these are people like I was
when I grew up we had this campaign
where they're going to briefly put all
the people who spoke Spanish in East LA
and all the people who didn't in Compton
or wants so that we could do a voting
rights drive we did it's fantastic
voting register at cuz the rest
marca proposition on the ballot and it
was you know people told me girlfriends
is they're going to send you to Compton
you're going to get people who despise
you and hate you because you're white or
they hate you because you're working
with the farmer person they see those as
those Mexicans and they're not going to
like you both of those things happen
once each very briefly in every other
experience I had it was like wow these
people are fantastic they come over to
me and say what can I do to help they
would say oh no shop your shirt fine you
know I we were asked see if he could get
volunteers for the summer and I said
yeah I'm gonna get people in Compton
comics to say okay I was begging stomach
doing five dollars a week plus room and
board no problem I mean you know it's
just amazing people were so embracing
and I said ha sworn even teach next year
my god and true name schools here I mean
families here that's how I became
conscious and politicized and I loved
working in Compton Ice up there for two
and a half years but we couldn't make it
through a summer vacation without
borrowing so when I got a chance to work
in LA I signed up for watts which was
pretty close teaching like I said it's
just the most time-consuming job because
when you come home from kindergarten you
look at all these twenty papers and you
go she made the a correctly and all
those put a sticker on it I love
teaching I hated what they did with
education eventually it just got to be
like too rigid and too much teaching
those things that are going to be tested
and making sure the kids learn those
skills because those were going to be on
the test I would do things to make it
makes a lesson come alive and I would
just be afraid that the principal would
walk in on me while I'm doing something
that's not in the script they made these
book
just before Christmas that I'd have them
think about if you could give a present
to anybody in the world what would it be
and if there is a homeless you don't
just think about money food and clothes
think about what if he could give them
homes and what with the Hong's be like
and what would they have in their
community and if there were people that
were too lonely maybe they weren't poor
but they were lonely what kind of
friends would you like to give them and
they were coming up with I give
wonderful little foster kids to the
lonely old people they should come from
foster kids or you know there was just
like so great but that's the sort of
thing I'm get in trouble for because I'm
not I can't do that anymore I have to
just stick with the script and so the
the year that it came clear that none of
that was being allowed anymore was a
friend of mine my 80 year old friend
said she just loved reading their
stories and it just she realized what
wonderful kids i had so i told my class
that and these were kids that I said
tell me about your class what do people
think of your class well we're the worst
class in school people are really hated
when we come you know it's just like
that was their self-image so I told him
what my neighbor said I made copies of
the books that they had made and reading
and saying their assignment was to write
an essay saying people say bad things
about our class but it's not true
because this is the sort of things we
write and they loved it and they're very
quiet and the principal walked in that
this is great she walks in when they're
all this class it is so hard to keep
them quiet and on task just just so into
the word I got in trouble for it and
that's when I was told you know you are
not to do anything that's not in me
teacher's manual and
just like and then it just went worse
from there I'm retype took early
retirement and I've never regretted that
I miss kids that's why I volunteered
with the pan-african film festival with
the student fest so at least once a year
get to help bring the kids from the bus
us into the theater when they get the
free filming and talk with them and yeah
I love that so I missed the kids i miss
a teaching but i just don't mess that
other stuff that was going on you know
and then when i retired i have much more
time and just less money for things like
entering them into screenplay contest
which thanks pants on an interview with
john sayles whom I just really really
loved he was being interviewed by David
Berg Samia of alternative radio and
David asked them so do you have any
advice to give to new filmmakers and
without a pause to think it over John
sale said yeah get a life basically what
he said was you know kids come out of
college they go to film school they
graduate they never had a real job
they've never worked as a working person
in you know and then they go make a
movie about life without having ever
lived it they said do you want to make
good films do something with your life
and then go make the film later so i
thought i love that i spent two and a
half decades teaching and having the
most amazing experiences in compton and
once with these absolutely wonderful
young people i traveled the world you
know wherever there's people do trying
to change their way of the
they're treated from cuva to Palestine
to you know Central America I you know
this is my life I just haven't gone to
film school strengthened oh great John
sales model event okay somebody said
listen if you bring a really good script
you can throw it out of the window your
car and somebody will pick up and that
movie will get made because it's and I'm
going well not if it's about you know a
labor union struggle uh none of it's
about anything I would write about maybe
if it was rombo six or you know the
Terminator you know whatever number were
on but my kind of movie no we should
have an organization made up both felt
progressive filmmakers the right of the
directors the Danny Glover's and Susan
Sarandon zand that you know all these
really great people that are out there
and they're doing big walked picket
lines but also the activists including
activists who have never even thought of
making movies but they love going to
them and they know the stories that
should be on the big screen obviously
avatar didn't need our help it was the
best watch movie a long time you know
that kind of a movie where you don't
need to do a documentary showing that
yet what war is all about one of the
things that either the agent or the
manager said is you get me a screenplay
that has and this is what he described
as we should be submitting to him he
said an action film with a male
protagonist and the female in a romantic
subservient role and so I said okay um
so during the Q&A I raised my hand I
said I've written an action film with a
female protagonist and a male and a
romantic subservient role and I don't
want you to get it to the studios I want
you
to get it to an independent production
company run by a producer with a social
conscience I would like to find an agent
a manager with a social conscience how
would I do that and he said quote we
don't have social conscience in the
coolant you know there's that whole
thing about is a glass half empty and
half horse a half full well you know
obviously it's both but you can choose
you can choose to be happy and one of
the things I did when I'm stitching and
wants sometimes I'd have kids that we
really had really bad things in their
lives and we're quite negative and then
I i just want i put up a sign over my
bullet my chalkboard saying choose to be
happy because you know things are really
problematic and messed up in some ways
but there are some wonderful things and
you can choose to say okay I know
there's war and you know what government
is doing to people all over the world
very often is terrible I know that I'd
hear about napalm on children and I'd
hear that fire hoses and police batons
on african-american civil rights
activist and I wouldn't want to know
about I mean it's just like I don't want
to know about things I can't do anything
about but on the other hand once I found
out and that's what I learned through
this United Farm Workers thing is I can
be part of a solution so yeah there are
these terrible things about going on but
you know where afterwards we're working
on and we're going to straighten it up I
pitch this story and afterwards she said
well I love your story but after nine
eleven Studios won't do anything on
police brutality because it's considered
unpatriotic and those were her exact
words and I just thought oh great now
when the police get to beat people up
and we can't say anything
Paul Haggis once said if you are writing
about something that has a whole lot of
social reality and you're skipping that
and you're you're avoiding it that's a
political movie it's a political
decision to not deal with the issues he
said those are just easier to sell and I
looked at them that's one of the reasons
I found it breakthrough is that idea
that if you're really writing about
police brutality or the war or you know
people struggling against a system to
get out of poverty not just a you know
struggling against those things that may
have made this one person fall into
poverty but against the systemic things
that cause but if you're writing my pad
it's really too scary so what we wanted
to do with breakthrough is support that
kind of filmmaking and have people whose
stories should be on the big screen my
favorite movie of all time is song to
the urine and it came out in 1954 and I
saw it in the 70s when I was
volunteering bolt on with the United
Farm Workers like I said it was really a
political in college in the 60s but I'm
going ok I want to be a writer and I
just see how making a movie like this
could just change people's attitudes
towards themselves and towards others
and towards women and towards people of
color and type writer is mightier than
the sword and the where the computer is
mightier than the sword whatever use
writing is just such an empowering thing
it the suburbs are just too
oh I think this up too nice to me what I
love most about Los Angeles and I'm
living in Koreatown now come to the
heart of LA is that LA has so many
peoples so I saw is a plane up from new
filmmakers the LA and it was a contest a
call for a contest to produce a 4-minute
Orphic last film on what your LA so I
what I love about la is the ethnic
diversity so I wrote this very short
story about little kids discovering the
ethnic wonders of Los Angeles so it got
into the film festival it was one of the
24 that were selected and as finalists
and my cast which were almost seven year
old a and a 13 year old and a couple of
kids in between all got to see
themselves on the kind of a big screen
it's a medium sized screen and have
people come up to them and say ooh you
were in that film you were very good it
was just really exciting it's like one
of the last things you see is this mural
and above it it says the Byzantine
Latino quarters and the mural is of two
angels each with one wing with the arms
around each other and it says we're all
angels with one wing we only fly by
embracing a chilling so that's what our
movie ended up with that's my la
I asked a friend of mine who is a SAG
actress and she read one my shortest
screenplays it's called mother earth
speaks and you never see the other woman
but I wanted an african-american voice
so i got this woman who is just really
great and that's just basically the
whole film thank you women and film for
producing two really good and just as my
mom used to call me the most extroverted
introvert she had ever met but I do love
people especially if they're really
doing wonderful things the activist
community other teachers other people
were involved in relating to life and
being alive I just their constant
inspiration at the end of the day no
matter what I've lived and I've affected
other people and other people have
affected me people have loved me and
I've loved others I've taught little
kids and I know sometimes they come back
into my life and say him it's like and
she remember me i was in your third
grade closets look people remember me
and they actually sometimes come up and
say you taught me this and i know
someday what I write is going to be on
the big screen and it's going be in
children's books where little kids and
their mommies can pick it up even the
little things like if I write a
political SI and II Blass it out and
somebody said hey you know I really
liked what you wrote and I it really
nailed it and it was really what we
needed to hear I just feel soaked I feel
so good like I've lived and I'm touch
people you know that's all in the peace
and justice movement let's all be
struggling for me that's it is a world
in which every single person
can all that they can touch other
people's lives in some way and that they
are real and they mean something we all
need